Annette Wild Goose holds a luggage tag
from her late mother's trip aboard the
MS St Louis a ship full of Jewish
refugees fleeing Germany in 1939 turned
away by Nations including Canada there's
a stark juxtaposition for her between
Canada's attitude towards Jews before
and during the second world war and new
information about how our country
accepted Nazis after these individuals
eradicated all of my family so I have no
cousins aunts and uncles we're at that
juter position now where we have to
learn from
history the Scandal over a former member
of the Nazi Waffen SS receiving a
standing ovation in the House of Commons
last fall renewed a push by Jewish
groups just showed an astonishing
historical ignorance uh and and sort of
reinforce the need to get the records
out the now more complete version of the
rodal report details then Justice
Minister Pierre Trudeau's take on a
laian Canadian known as subject F
convicted in absentia by the Soviet
Union as the captain of a firing squad
which murdered
5,128 Jews in 1967 Trudeau was against
stripping subject F's citizenship
writing the applicant's obligation is to
satisfy the court that he is of good
character he is not required to satisfy
the court that he at no time in his past
committed an appropriate act there is
more information yet to be released
including the names of 240 suspected
Nazi war criminals we cannot learn the
mistakes of the past until we see the
records of the past and so this is an
effort not just about the past but it's
also an effort about the present this is
uh both an important part of the
historical record but also uh one that
has uh implications around privacy uh
around uh Community cohesion and this
was can prob Abigail bman Global News
Ottawa